Hi!
So welcome to the
third part of the
autonomic series.
We're now covering
the head and neck.
If you have any
questions always feel
free to reach out.
My email is on there.
So after this session
you should be able
to compare and contrast
sympathetic and
parasympathetic
innervation to the head
and neck. You should
be able to list the
four parasympathetic
ganglia of the head
and their pre-ganglia
input and output.
Understand the
innervation and
function of the
glands on the head.
explain Horner's
syndrome and explain
accommodation
convergence reflex so do
a little bit of repeat
you've seen this
before a couple of
times now so we're
covering the peripheral
nervous system
there's also central
nervous system which
is the brain and
spinal cord which
you'll learn more
about in your anatomy
but now we're focusing
on the peripheral
nervous system and we
had somatic innervation
and visceral innervation
so we're focusing
only on the visceral
innervation now it's
cardiac muscles muscle
and glands and then
we have sensory and
motor for that remember
that they are the two
different neuron types
so we have those
visceral motor neurons
which is a two-neuron system
with the preganglionic
and postganglionic
neuron and you have
the preganglionic
neuron that starts out
in the central nervous
system so in the brain
or spinal cord and
then synapses outside
of the central nervous
system in certain
autonomic ganglia
and then you have a
postganglionic or postsynaptic
axon that synapses
on the target organ
itself for the wristful
sensory neurons those
are bipolar neurons
so you have a cell body
kind of in the center
that sits outside of
the central nervous
system you have a
signal that's coming in
from an organ or from
the body ball and then
synapses in the central
nervous system we
might just to contrast
sympathetics and
parasympathetics both are
those two neuron system
those motor systems
the pre-gagnionic cell
bodies for sympathetics
can be found
between t1 and l2 versus
the parasympathetics
are either in the
brain stem or s3s4
postganglionic cell
bodies for sympathetic and
pervertible ganglia or
subdiaphragmatic ganglia
and those for the
parasympathetics are in
the walls of the organ
or in my new pelvic
ganglia or in those
four ganglia in the head
and neck which we'll
finally get to today
so what are those
types of structures
with those structures
in the head
that we want to
innovate Also, we
have the lacrimal
gland, mucus gland,
salivary gland, we
have sweat glands on
the face, we have
sebaceous glands, like
the tarsal glands,
or myelbium glands.
And then there's
smooth muscle
structures, like
blood vessels, we
have very small
muscles in the eye,
superior tarsal,
constrictor pupillae,
dilated pupillae, or
ciliary muscle. so for
those structures we
want to get innervation
to the head okay now
talking a little bit
about the functions
of the autonomic
nervous system so for
the head and neck it's
often that only one
of them is really
having an effect so it's
either the sympathetics
or it's the
parasympathetics so that
you can see this in
lachman gland it's not
quite clear what the
sympathetics are doing
there, they're going
there, but it's not
quite sure what
they're actually doing.
The secretion
is really done
by the parasympathetics.
For sweat glands,
that's only done
by sympathetics.
Parasympathetics
have nothing to
do with that.
Superior tarsal muscle
and dilator pupillae,
they're both done
by the sympathetics,
versus constrictor
pupillae and ciliary
muscle are done by
the parasympathetics.
now there are a couple
of things that have
this dual innovations
so the salivary glands
for example but their
effect is a little
different so the
sympathetics when they
are active for salivary
glands they actually
secrete like a really
dense saliva so think
of when you're very
nervous and your mouth
gets like dry that
dense saliva that's
the sympathetic effect
versus parasympathetics
when you're hungry
and you're salivating
to put like get food
down right that's
the effect of the
parasympathetics it's much
more liquid saliva
and then for blood
vessels it's also a
little different it kind
of depends on where
those blood vessels are
so a sympathetic effect
of facial arteries
is actually dilation
like think of when
someone is blushing like
that's a very that's
a sympathetic effect
um that you can see
now let's focus on
sympathetics um after
this little intro so
here's our overview slide
of the sympathetics
remember pre-ganglionics
like all good
sympathetics start in the
lateral horn and for
the head and neck
specifically we start
between t1 and t2 then we
have the are preganglionic
axons that take
their regular pathway
into the sympathetic
chain through the
ventral root, the spinal
nerve, ventral rami,
right rami, communicants,
and then into the
parative ganglion. And
then they ascent in
the sympathetic chain.
And for the head specifically,
they will synapse
in the superior
cervical ganglion. For
the neck, they might
also synapse in the
middle cervical or
inferior cervical ganglion.
And then for the head
specifically, you
have the postganglionics
that pass with
the internal and
external carotid plexus
so what does this
look like um if you're
looking at the anatomy
here you can see this
is like kind of a
pathway dissected neck
you're looking at the
right side and you
can see the sympathetic
chain here so you
have the inferior
cervical ganglion middle
cervical ganglion
and superior cervical
ganglion, remember
that those ganglia, a
couple of ganglia fused
of the cervical levels,
like in particular
superior cervical
ganglion fused C1 to
C4 parvotibic ganglia.
So most of those
preganglionic sympathetics
will just ascent
all the way up to
the superior cervical
ganglion and synapse
there. That's where
most of the post
-kingleonic sympathetic
cell bodies are.
And you can see the
size is really big.
So now this is a
kind of bisected
view, and you're
looking at the
medial aspect of
the left side.
and you can see in
there the superior
cervical ganglion and
then you can see the
external carotid plexus
so you just have those
post ganglionics passing
with the external
carotid artery to
the places where the
external carotid artery
goes and then you
also have the internal
carotid nerve that
just kind of looks like
the continuation of
the sympathetic chain
but really important
sympathetic chain are
preganglionics the
internal carotid nerve
those are postganglionics
right so the
sympathetic chain kind
of stops at the superior
cervical ganglion
and then it just
continues as those
postganglionics in the
internal carotid nerve
that forms a little
plexus around the internal
carotid artery and
then it branches into
the orbit and part
of the nasal cavity
like more specifically
here this is kind of
what the internal
carotid plexus all does
so i'm not going to
go through all of
them but just to
to point out a few
so this is like
vasoconstriction of the
ocular arteries we
have the dilator
pupillae and superior
tarsal muscles
and then the
vasodilation of facial
arterials covering
the forehead
For the ones
that are passing
with the depetrosal
nerves, they're
going to the
lacronal gland,
and then also
vasoconstriction of blood
vessels in the nasal
cavity, palate, pharynx.
So think of
everything that is
kind of passing
with that depetrosal
nerve into the
nasal cavity.
so for the external
carotid plexus um you
can think of anywhere
where the external
carotid artery goes
that is where you
get the innervation
tube so like with
the maxillary artery
it's kind of going to
the parietic gland
the lingual artery
it's going to sublingual
and submandibular
gland but branches
of the facial artery
might pass to the
submandibular gland
and then with all
of those branches
you know it's going
to arteries well
it's innervating
the arteries that
it's passing with
and it will go
through to facial
sweat glands as well
so that was already
the pattern for the
sympathetics it's actually
um now we're finally
getting to the point
where the sympathetics
are actually not that
complicated anymore
um i feel like where
the parasympathetics
are going to be a little
bit more complicated
But one of the important
clinical considerations
here that you
probably see for your
broad studies as well
is Horner's syndrome.
So what is that?
So here is two
images of
Horner's syndrome.
Horner's syndrome
is a blockage of
the sympathetic
pathway to the head.
And you can see here,
in this case on Bose,
it's the left side
that is impacted.
and often you hear of
a triad of symptoms
but there are other
symptoms that you
can actually see really
well here as well
but the the kind of
big symptoms that
you're looking out for
is a constricted pupil
dropping of the
upper eyelid and lack
of sweating and so you
can see that little
drop of the eyelid
pretty well here
that is lack of the
superior tarsal muscle
that is causing
that wall drop. You
have the constricted
pupil because your
dilator pupillae is
not working anymore.
It's all, you know,
done by sympathetics.
And you have a
lack of sweating.
Remember, sweat
glands are all
done by the
sympathetics. So
you have this
lack of sweating.
But what you can also
see very nicely here
is that you lose
vasodilation in the face. So
you cannot blush
anymore so in particular
in the lower image you
can see that really
well that one side that
is affected the skin
is like not red at all
and often you see that
compensatory effect on
the other side where
you see like a lot of
blushing on that side
and then sometimes
you also see loss of
ocular vasoconstriction
so like your your
vessels and your eye
cannot constrict anymore
they're kind of dilated
and they might look
what's called blood shots
so a little bit more
red i think that's a
little bit better seen
in the upper image
it's slightly more red
so it's not as easy
to see but i think
like the the vasodilation
is the kind of
blush is pretty easy
to see in those images
now for the horner
syndrome you
typically think
of this as the
whole you know
neural pathway
i in the lectures
that we've covered so
far will always have
always just talked
about the preganglionic
and postganglionic
axons so the
preganglionic here
that's the red axon
or a red neuron that
is referred to as a
second-order neuron.
And then the
postganglionic coming from
the superior cervical
ganglion and then
passing with the
internal and external
carotid, this is
called the third-order
neuron. So there's
also a neuron that
is in the central
nervous system itself.
So I haven't
covered that. You
will cover that
in neuroanatomy.
But there is a
pathway right from the
brain, actually,
into the spinal cord
synapsing on that
prekanglionic axon. So,
in fact, there's
really three neurons
involved in that
sympathetic pathway, one
central one and then
two peripheral one.
Now, different parts
can be here affected.
So you can have a
first-order neuron
disorder that's like
****** or tumor or spinal
cord trauma. trauma,
so anything that is
actually happening in
the central nervous
system that impacts
that whole pathway.
You can also
have a second
-order neuron disorder.
Often you see this
with tumors in the
lung that are compressing
the sympathetic
chain or compressing
the inferior,
the parvotary ganglion.
Those tumors are all
called pancos tumors,
so that's the kind of
tumor that does that.
And then we also
have a third order
neuron disorder.
So that would be a
neuron disorder of
the postganglionic
pathways, like a
lesion to the internal
acquired artery or
external acquired
artery or injury
to the skull base.
So you will see
different patterns with
those neuron disorders.
So the first and
second order neuron
disorder, they will look
the same, like
everything is impacted
right so you're impacting
the whole pathway
so that means like
both you you see your
whole side of the
face where you can see
the lack of sweating
and the lack of blushing
the third order
neuron disorder is the
one that's a little
different so there you
either have the internal
credit or external
credit impacted so
half of it would
still be working In
most cases, this is
actually internal
carotid, much more common.
So in that case, for
the internal carotid,
you do see the
impacts on the eye.
So you see that mild
drop of the eyelid.
You see the constriction
of the pupil.
You also see then
that you cannot blush
on the forehead and
that you cannot sweat
on the forehead.
But for the rest of
the face, which is
done by the external
crowded artery and then
the external crowded
plexus, that is
still functional. So
that blushing or
like sweating on that
side of the face would
still be working.
But again, first
order, second order,
neuron disorder,
they would look the
same. You're impacting
both internal
and external
crowded, so you have
the whole half of
the face impacted.
Okay, now wrapping
this up into a clinical
scenario, like
something that you
might see on the exam,
right? So here we
have a 25-year-old
male presence to your
practice with left
-sided mild pitosis in
a constricted pupil.
You had a CT scan,
which shows a tumor
in the superior lobe
of the left lung.
You suspect the tumor
is compressing the
sympathetic chain.
Which other symptoms
would you expect to
see? Okay, so you
already know from this,
there's a tumor,
probably a Panko's tumor
in the left lung, and
it's compressing the
sympathetic chain.
So you know this is a
second-order neural
disorder that will
impact the whole
sympathetic pathway to that
site. We know it's
left-sided, and I've
already given you
two of the symptoms,
which is mild pitosis
because your superior
tassel muscle is
not working and also
constricted pupil because
your dilator pupillary
is not working now
the other symptoms
that you will see is
lack of sweating right
so losing innervation
to the sweat glands
you'll see that on
the whole half side
cannot blush on
the left side
that would also
be correct so
two answers correct
a and b here
You cannot blush
because you are losing
the dilation of
facial arterials.
Bloodshot right
eye, that would be
incorrect. It
would be bloodshot
on the left side
because you're losing
constriction of
ocular vessels.
Redness of the left
face, that is also
incorrect. If you see
redness, that would be
on the right side,
right? So the right side
would be overcompensating.
you would see
redness on the right
side but not on the
left side where you
cannot blush anymore.
Dry mouth you wouldn't
see that either
that is caused by
sympathetic and
right now sympathetics
are not working.
Okay now that we
covered the sympathetic
labs move on to the
parasympathetics
and they are a
little bit more
complicated for
the head and neck.
okay so for parasympathetic
innovation big
picture right now um as
we're finally getting
to those four ganglia
in the um head
that we've mentioned all
through those lectures
this is the ciliary
ganglion tercopalatine
ganglion submandibial
ganglion and otic
ganglion and in the
rest of the lecture i
will go through this
ganglion by ganglion
and what is their
preganglionic input, and
how do postganglionic
travels from there.
So just big picture
generally, right,
there are a couple of
cranial nerves that
bring preganglionic
axons to those ganglia.
So for the ciliary
ganglion, that's
the oculomotor nerve.
For the pterogopelotide
ganglion, that's
the facial nerve.
For the submantibular
ganglion, that's
the facial nerve.
And for the otic
ganglion, that's the
glossopharyngeal nerve.
then they synapse in
those ganglia and then
they pass with branches
of the trigeminal
nerve to actually get
to the structures that
they need to go to so
the postganglionics
will pass with the
trigeminal nerve this
is just a different
way of showing this and
showing like other
branches as well so here
in red is the
parasympathetics so you can
see those preganglionic
axons that are
passing with the
oculomotor, the facial,
glossopharyngeal. Then
when you're getting into
the rest of the
parasympathetics for
the neck, there's
also the vagus
nerve, but that's
not covered here.
But so they're passing
with those cranial
nerves to the ganglia,
here's here ganglion,
ciliary ganglion,
tergopalatine ganglion,
submittibial ganglion,
and otic ganglion.
And then the post
-ganglionics will pass with
the branches of the
trigeminal nerve to
the structures that
they need to innervate.
You also see here
the sympathetics
in blue. And keep
in mind, when you're
in the head,
the sympathetics
that you see are
all post-ganglionic.
Because all the pre
-ganglionics have all
synapsed in the
superior cervical
ganglion. So any
sympathetics that you see
in the head are post
-ganglionic. versus
you can see the
preganglionic and
postganglionic
parasympathetics in the head.
So there are other
neurons that pass through
those ganglia, but the
ganglia exist because
those are the locations
of the cell bodies
of the postganglionic
parasympathetics.
So now I'll start
with the first
one, that's the
ciliary ganglion.
So for the ciliary
ganglion, preganglionic
cell bodies are
found in the brain.
I've added the nucleus
here as well. you
will cover that in
your anatomy. I will
not ask you about this
from this lecture.
The preganglionic
axon pass
with the
oculomotor nerve.
Then the postganglionic
cell bodies are
found in the ciliary
ganglion and postganglionic
axons pass with the
short ciliary to the
ciliary muscle and
constrictor pupillae.
This is just a visual
of that so you can see
that oculomotor nerve
with the preganglionics.
You can see the
ciliary ganglion and
then the synapse there
on the postganglionics
which are the kind of
dotted lines here and
that going to those
little ocular muscles.
You can also see
added here again the
sympathetic postganglionic
pathway to the eye
as well and general
sensory back now what
do they do there right
so we said that's
the ciliary muscle
and the constrictor
pupillae and they
are responsible for
constriction and
accommodation what does this
mean so pupillary
constriction is when too
much light is shown
into your eyes and
your pupils constrict
that's a consensual
reflex so this means
if you shine light
into one eye both
pupils should construct.
You also do this
when you're focusing
on objects that are
kind of close by.
Accommodation is
when the lens of
the eye assumes a
rounded shape or
when the shape of
the lens changes.
So you also put
them both together.
Accommodation and
convergence they often
happen together and
that is when you're
focusing on something
that's close by it's
like when I'm bringing
up my finger and
I'm focusing on it I'm
actually using both
the constrictor
pupillae and the ciliary
muscle to constrict
the pupil and to
change the shape of the
lens so that you can
focus on that object
okay let's go through
this in a little bit
more detail so this is
what accommodation
looks like so again this
is when the lens changes
its shape so in a
relaxed state when the
ciliary muscle is relaxed
you have the lens
that is kind of very
flat and long and it's
suspended by the suspensory
ligaments which attach
onto the ciliary
muscle and so when the
ciliary muscles relax
those sense suspensory
ligaments are kind
of taut and they kind
of drag out the the
lens to be like longer
then when the ciliary
muscle contracts it
actually bulges into the
eye like think of this
as um when you have
your biceps brachii and
you're contracting it
and then it like bulges
well not not in my
case but like and some
people have like really
big biceps brachii
they kind of bulge out
right um but that's
that's basically what
the ciliary muscle
does as well so you
have that ciliary
muscle and you contract
it and it kind of
gets rounder and
that releases that
tension from the
suspensory ligaments
so those suspensory
ligaments then are not
as taut they kind of
flop back and the
lens becomes rounder
so the lens wants
to be round but it's
kind of getting
stretched by the
suspensory ligaments
when the ciliary muscle
is relaxed when the
ciliary muscle is
contracted that
tension is gone and the
lens jumps back to
its rounded shape
and so that will
change the angle
of the light rays
into the retina
so now when we're
looking at accommodation
and convergence together
so here on the left
side you can see the
ciliary muscle is
relaxed and those suspensory
ligaments are taut
and the lens is really
flat and you can
also see the pupil is
um like open or dilated
now if the accommodation
and convergence
reflex is active what
you see is that the
ciliary muscle is
contracted so the
suspensory ligaments
are not as taut the lens
assumes this rounder
shape and then you
also have the constrictor
pupillae which
will constrict and
then close off and
constrict the pupil
now keep in mind right
constriction that
is done by the
parasympathetics and that
is to allow less light
in so it's a reaction
to a lot of light
and then you're
constricting the pupil
dilation is done by
sympathetics so i think
about like fight and
flight when you want
to have like all the
light into your eyes
you want to see as much
as possible or when
you see someone who's
very nervous um like
their pupils dilate
um so that is done by
sympathetics so you
can see that big uh
pupil here to allow more
light in okay so moving
on to the next
ganglion so we covered
ciliary ganglion now
we're heading into the
tergopalatine ganglion
so for that by starting
out with preganglionic
cell bodies in
the brain again i'm
adding the nucleus here
you'll see that in
neuroanatomy but don't
have to be worried about
this now then we're
going with the
preganglionic axons with
the facial nerve
passing with the great
epitrosal and the nerve
of the terrogate canal
then the postganglionic
cell bodies are in
the terropelatine genome
and the postganglionic
axons will pass with
direct branches to
the lacronal gland or
to with branches of v2
to the mucous glands
in the nasal cavity
pellet sinus pharynx so
here's what this looks
like right you have
your facial nerve coming
in it will give up
the greater petrosal
nerve here then pass
into the pterygoid canal
where it's the nerve
of the pterygoid canal
synapse on the pterygo
palatine ganglion
and then we'll pass to
the lacron gland with
direct branches or
into the nasal cavity
and pellet with branches
of v2 so here's a
little more anatomical
view of this right so
you have your teregopelatine
ganglion here in
the teregopelatine
fossa you have your
greater petrosal nerve
teregorete the nerve of
the teregorete canal
coming in as your
teregopelatine ganglion,
and then just all the
branches of B2 that are
passing through, like
your lesser palatine,
greater palatine, and
all of the branches
in the nasal cavity
that are providing
innervation to the mucosa.
Okay, next one. So
now we're moving on to
submandibular
ganglion, and we have
preganglionic cell
bodies in the
brain, preganglionic
axons passing with
the facial nerve,
but this time we're
going to take the chorda
tympani to the lingual
nerve then we're
going with postgagnionic
cell bodies in
the submandibial ganglion
and synapsing there
on those cell bodies
and the postgangionic
axons we'll just go
direct branches to
the submandibial gland
or we'll hop onto
the lingual nerve again
and then go to the
sublingual gland and
there's a more diagrammatic
view of the anatomy
here so So you
see that facial
nerve, we can see the
caudatympani coming up,
we saw that caudatympani
join the lingual nerve
and the infratemporal
fossa, and then going
to the submandibular
ganglion, synapse
there, and then go
to the sublingual and
submandibular gland.
So here's this really
more anatomical
view of the
infratemporal fossa and
all cavities, so
you can see those
nice branches of the
lingual nerve and
overall of the
mandibular division
of the trigeminal
nerve you can see
quadratympani joining
the lingual nerve
then the
submandibular ganglion
being suspended from
the lingual nerve
and you can see those
direct branches to
the submandibular
gland or again it's
going to hop back on
those post ganglionics
onto the lingual nerve
and then go to the
sublingual gland to
innervate it here.
Okay last ganglion
is the otic ganglion.
Again we start in
the brain now this
time we're passing with
the glossopharyngeal
nerve that turns
into topenic nerve,
topenic plexus,
lesser patrols nerve.
We're hitting the otic
ganglion where the
post ganglionic cell
bodies are and then
passing with the
auriculotemporal nerve to
the parotid gland a
bit of a diagrammatic
view here but that's
your glossopharyngeal
nerve passing through
the jugular foramen
kind of scratching
by the ear with the
tympanic plexus through
the lesser petrosal nerve
where getting to the
otic ganglion synapsing
there then with the
auriculotemporal
nerve that will pass
those branches, those
postganglionic branches
to the parotid gland.
So that's just a
different view of that,
where you can see the
parasympathetic pathway,
preganglionic and
postganglionic,
and also those
postganglionic
sympathetics that
will pass with the
external carotid to
the parotid gland.
So that's kind of what
you're seeing here.
okay now not what he
mentioned with those
uh four ganglia in the
head but other structures
in the neck that
you want to innovate
and um that are
parasympathetic and that's
done by the vagus nerve
so remember the vagus
nerve was that was
the big nerve that was
providing parasympathetics
to the thorax and
most of the abdomen
it also provides
parasympathetic to the
neck so for that we're
just starting off with
the brain pregame leonics
going with the vagus
nerve you're synapsing
close to the target
organ it's kind of
the same as with the
thorax and abdomen right
you saw the same
pattern with the
parasympathetics there
and then it just goes to
glands and blood vessels
in the pharynx and
mucus glands and blood
vessels in the larynx
so that's pretty simple
pattern right we have
those branches of the
vagus nerve we have
the pharyngeal branches
that go to pharyngeal
glands we have the
superior laryngeal nerve
and the recurrent
laryngeal nerve that will
then innervate the
larynx itself superior
laryngeal will provide
parasympathetics above
the vocal fold and the
recurrent laryngeal
will provide
parasympathetics below the
vocal fold so yeah just
that side view of the
larynx you can see
that superior laryngeal
nerve branching from
the vagus nerve and then
you see the internal
branch that will pass
into the larynx that's
that parasympathetic
innovation and you can
also see that recurrent
laryngeal nerve
looping back up again
between the trachea and
the esophagus and then
moving into the
larynx as the inferior
laryngeal nerve that
provides the motor innovation
to all those muscles
in the larynx, but
also parasympathetics
to those mucous glands
below the vocal
folds. And it's
also going to
innovate this
thyroid and
parathyroid gland.
So here's that cut-up
section. So you can
see that once it
passes into the larynx,
it's called inferior
laryngeal to match the
superior laryngeal.
So we have like nice
convergence here of
those nerves. Remember,
this is all vagus
nerve, like big picture,
parasympathetics to
the neck is done by the
vagus nerve now this is
a really nice summary
of the parasympathetics
so if you like
really understand this
diagram like you understand
parasympathetics
this is listing all
the parasympathetics
that are done by cranial
nerves so everything
to the head and then
also everything that
the vagus nerve does so
I think this is a really
nice summary to look
into okay now that we've
covered parasympathetic
and sympathetic
innovation to the
head let's think about some
clinical considerations
here so I want to
let's start with
damage to ocular motor
nerve here what might
be causes for ocular
motor nerve damage to
motor nerve palsy
pituitary gland tumor which
the pituitary gland
sits right at the base
of the oculomotor nerve
or aneurysms and some
of the cerebral arteries
that are passing
very close to the
oculomotor nerve as well.
And some of the
symptoms that you would
see, I remember
that the oculomotor
nerve is bringing
the preganglionic
parasympathetics to
the eye and they are
doing the constrictor
pupillae and also
the ciliary muscle
so you would lose the
accommodation and
convergence reflex and
typically the pupil
will be dilated on their
side so there's no
there's only the
sympathetics that would
dilate the pupil but
there's no effect of
the parasympathetics
anymore that would
constrict the pupil
You will also
see, of course,
somatic motor loss
to the ocular muscles
as well as to the
upper eyelid. So your
upper eyelid will drop
on the affected side,
more so even than
with the sympathetic
innervation, what
we've seen with Horner
syndromes. And then
you will see impairment
of certain eye movements
that you will go
over in the ocular
muscle lecture as well.
Now just to show
you something
that's a little bit
out of the ordinary
here which is
Frey's syndrome.
So this is just nuts
what nerves can do.
This is pretty common
syndrome after a
parotid gland surgery
or trauma to that
region but commonly
if you have the
parotid gland removed,
like some studies
say between 30 and
50% of the cases, it
happens that you
get Frey's syndrome,
which is also called
gustatory sweating.
So in this case,
what is happening is
that the auricular
motor, which is, you
know, getting all
those parasympathetics
or carrying all
those post-gagnionic
parasympathetics responsible
for innervating the
parotid gland will
actually grow back to
innervate sweat glands
and vessels so stuff
that is actually
taken on by that that
should be taken on by
sympathetics are suddenly
innervated by the
oricotemporal from
parasympathetics and the
effect of that is that
if you like when you're
a parasympathetic
gland when your
parotid gland should be
stimulated for you know
you see food or you
smell food and you
should have saliva
secretion what instead
happens on that side is
that you're sweating
and it becomes very
red so you can see
that here in the image
you can see that scar
of the product gland
surgery and you can see
the sweating and the
redness on that size
and it kind of goes
up all the way to the
temples like all the
way the innervation
of your ericotemporal.
So this is kind
of a bizarre thing
that can happen when
neurons can regrow
but in this case
taking over a
completely different
function than it
had before and it
would still work.
Okay let's finish
this off with
another clinical
scenario where we can
bring in all of
this innovation.
So this is 35-year
-old female presents to
the office with the
following symptoms,
pitosis and constrictor
pupil on the right
side. Which nerve is
most likely damaged?
First option is
optic nerve and
that would be
incorrect. So what
wouldn't be working
with the optic
nerve is, with
regards to the pupil,
is that the pupillary
light reflex wouldn't
work. What does
this mean? So if you
shine a light into one
eye and that the optic
nerve is not working
on that side it
cannot really receive
that there's light shown
into the eye so it
wouldn't trigger
constriction of the
pupil if you then move
over to the other side
that is not affected
it would you would
see you would see the
light and it would trigger
constriction of both
pupils so construction
of the pupil would
work on the side that
is not on both sides
if you shine in the
light that is in the
eye that is not
affected for trigeminal
nerve injury you would
lose sensory particular
for the eye now you
would lose sensory
to the cornea so in
this case you wouldn't
blink on that side
because there's nothing
that stimulates that
reflex when you're
touching the cornea
facial nerve is also
incorrect that's not
the symptoms that you
would see for the
facial nerve. Remember,
facial nerve, if that
is damaged, what you
would see for the eye
or orbit region is
that you wouldn't be
able to blink. So you
would lose orbicularis
ocular, but you also
have all those other
symptoms of Bell's
palsy, like dropping
corner of your mouth,
drooling, difficulty
smiling, and so on.
For oculomotor nerve,
that's the one that
we just discussed. So
what you would see there
from the parasympathetic
side is that you
would lose the constrictor
pupillae and the
ciliary muscle, so
you wouldn't have the
accommodation and
convergence reflex anymore.
your pupil would be
dilated so not constricted
but dilated because
you cannot constrict
anymore you would
see pitosis because
you're losing innervation
to ocular muscles you
would also see all the
other ocular muscle
impacts so like limited
adduction elevation
and depression of the
eye so typically your
eye assumes this um
out abducted position
now what is left here
is internal quadriplexus
so this is horner
syndrome right you
might have caught that
pitosis constrictor pupil
on that side okay now
wrapping up sympathetics
are really simple
right now pre
-ganglionic axons for the
head and neck are from
t1 to t2 lateral horn
they synapse in the
superior cervical ganglion
and then they will
pass with the internal
and external carotid
plexus parasympathetics
pre-ganglionics are
from four cranial
nerves as ocular motor
facial glossopharyngeal
and vagus nerve they
synapse in four ganglia
and then the post
-scanionics travel with
the trigeminal nerve.
The best references
for this from my
perspective are Jack
Stern's core concept.
But you can also, if you
want to really
dive into it,
Yannick 2006 is
a good reference.
I would always
appreciate your feedback.
Positive, negative
please let me know how
you're feeling about
this lecture and
what you would like
to see more or less of
that thank you and
please always feel free
to reach out if you
have any questions